une étude qui est sorti sachez que
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire et
et le télétravail le nombre
d'interventions de chirurgie esthétique
a augmenté de 20 à 30%
sachez que c'est surtout grâce à magali
bertin non mais c'est vrai il paraît que
comme on se retrouve chez soi en fait on
se regarde beaucoup dans le miroir et
comme c'est comme j'ai pu lire moi
pourquoi j'ai plein de potes joueur de
foot vous le savez je me suis jamais
caché
et je les hais les souvent au téléphone
et vous avez remarqué des joueurs de
foot qui changent tout le temps de
coiffure est fondée ils font des éclairs
ils font des petites couleurs même moi
c'est comme moi comme moi j'ai rien à
[ __ ] de la journée parfois c'est vrai
que tu fais que des animations
capillaires et ben en confinement comme
des chez toi tu es le banc ton miroir et
tu fais c'est vrai que mon oeil n'est
pas où cela tu vois je le verrai tout ce
que tu as à tes commence tu fais du tout
et pour le miroir un monde est grave
c'est pas si mal la blache vous comment
l'as tu va taper sur google theuriau des
gros shows bout là tu tombes sur braga
star ici et là des séries c'est pas nul
à la gauche pour commence à bout mais on
a vu pour combien de cravo aulas mois
entourant tooway à en finale peut-être
eu un échafaudage ou pas en tenir compte
au macaron finale et 48 autres vous vous
êtes profiter complètement
bah oui et 7 2011 à l aller repeal 2020
j'ai fait la poitrine j'ai fais tout moi
c'est bip aux deux fois mais moi j'adore
que les white mountains j'ai beau vous
dit les choses 10.2 fois donc oui j'ai
fait lit peu de fois j'ai fait un petit
ange hexion dans les fesses et je le
connais traduction de ce juriste
après la grèce dans la lipo et après
vous langer que dans les faits ça vous
fait bomber un petit peu les fesses ah
ouais
après j'ai fait quoi tout le visage non
ouais j'ai fait tout le visage mais
qu'ils ont sorti une photo de moi sur
les réseaux sociaux la dernière fois ils
vont faire un montage entre avant et
après mais même moi j'ai eu peur et
franchement je me suis dit heureusement
que j'ai fait un voidray mot à hu est on
arrête tes patins mais j'assume pardon
mais c'est très dur sur plus d'un mais
féminin parce que non mais moi j'ai un
problème c'est que j'ai voilà vous vous
sentez mieux aujourd'hui franchement
ouais c'est très dur de voir ses lancers
ouais j'ai refait les dents aussi oui
c'est bien de le dire voilà mais c'est
un vrai photo chéri c'est moi moi je
vous dire la vérité je vous trouve
magnifique aussi à jouer moi je la
trouve qu'ils avaient vu venir dans les
nous voir un jour j'ai dit à les
licencier
non c'est un vrai c'est un vrai complexe
je pense que la chirurgie quand on fait
faut vraiment avoir un vrai problème
ah ouais ouais mais ça c'est à moi ça
moi ça m'a ça m'a vraiment permis de me
sentir mieux et d'être mieux avec la
maison tu es mieux dans votre tête dans
votre coin concrets qui a fait de la
chirurgie à part casta castaldi tu ne
reviens demain demain demain chez les
mots pierre boulez des tomates et les
paupières dessin qui paraît voyez
confinement benhaim jamais rien non vous
avez raison vous sentez bien comme ça
baute j'assume en tout cas delphine
tadjeur truc ça mais c'est vrai n'ont
jamais tu devrais chi larue alors on a
beau chercher outil qu'est ce qu'un bar
offertes d'alvin c'est la perfection il
est parfait gtc je vous l'avais dit
c'est le une fois le lifting colombien
s'élévant tous sur les fesses mais bon
ça tient de moi quoi je joue en cabinet
des noms bien avec un ami
il dit aux gens qui avaient la tenue
hier qu'on avait dans le salon voilà
reviennent quand il avait sa tenue
perruque dire la langue et au jour tombe
d'ailleurs fait un truc dans lé 8 toi tu
vas faire des trucs c'est sur une
liposuccion peut-être des gens
passionnés non c'est vrai les élèves
ouais ouais et et toi ça te fait peur
toi saison toi tu as tu déjà non je sais
pas en fait je me refais mes cheveux
c'est tout ouais ouais ouais là tu as
fait comme un rideau en fait un plan
vert comme as eh bien je refais le blond
vous avez rien encore mais je suis pas
contre en revanche quand je me rase être
renouvellé coucougnettes un peu les
utiliser plus souvent non le truc c'est
que les paupières aussi célimène sont
lourdes peut-être j'ai peur de changer
vraiment le visage mais maintenant
envoyer en vieillissant j'ai 64 ans dans
quelques semaines des manies mais
justement justement à une époque c'était
c'était pas mal et l'art me regardant
bien tous les matins ça y est là on voit
qu'il ya 64 ans
il ya pas mal de rythme mais les cas
manquer si je continue à attraper comme
ça ça va
ohlala et il est beau comme ça nicolas
pernikoff vous moi j'ai jamais rien fait
mais c'est vrai que je suis un petit
complexe avec mes paupières lourdes
jeûner pendant 34 ans mais j'ai
paupières qui est bien là et ces mêmes
colonnes que ma dame âgée qui jugeront
nécessaire et ça doit marcher bras mais
un médecin mais dans le bâtiment c'est
vrai j'aurais bien avoir les yeux vous
allez voir est lundi castaldi laura les
yeux coassin ça est un truc de malade
vous êtes un mois j'aimerais le nez mais
le problème c'est gagné non ça vous va
nous dire comme ça annoncé jeudi que sa
marque de fabrique
d'accord mais sans rigoler c'est une
bonne idée c'est votre part de vos amis
que vous avez un gros nez si vous avez
de me traîner ça marchera pas c'est vrai
regardez vous êtes magnifiques comme ça
on oublie que les petits défauts ce
compte comptait sur les femmes aiment ça
qui fait aussi la beauté le caractère de
charisme d'une personne âgée qui
rassurera bien sûr humains cyril vous
auriez envie de changer quelque chose ou
pas bien sûr avec quoi l'équipe de
président